une fois que ça passe d'un comme des
collectivités en tout cas où un ajout au
maire adressa syndicalistes pensent le
contraire qui se passe là j'ai été
agressée heureuse de mes camarades ils
ont vu ce qui s'est passé à l'amiable le
maout il va bousculer son estomac à deux
reprises le poids conséquent
moi je j'étais surpris je n'ai pas réagi
je le dis j'ai dit cette personne ne me
touchait plus madame on m'a dit qu'il a
dit que je lui ai donné un coup de tenir
bon je sais pas mais je n'ai agressé par
mais tu étais l'exagèrent monsieur
grumman qui se sentent agressés par mais
tu étais je veux bien même si bon je
veux bien les cacher mais je n'ai pas
d'essai par l'éditeur un syndicaliste
avec une telle expérience 2 m
l'ag d'état 9 dont vous me voyez un peu
grosse mais quand même faire face à
monsieur gros maquis qui revendique
depuis des années qui a une longue
expérience de toutes les batailles qui
se présente en politique qui fait plein
de choses et je vais moi je vais
l'agresser droit à beaucoup d'estomac
face à la montée
je dois bousculade d'une dame au niveau
du coeur et je l'avais imbéciles en même
temps je sais même pas sa vie pour faire
un bon bout ce qu'une voix laval possède
à lui que j'ai j'ai été surpris de la
ville depuis samedi
je suis au fisc et monsieur woman ne
peut pas faire les féroces âme et été
parce que je suis une femme
c'est pas normal ça